yes
okay
let's
thanks a lot and i will start therefore
with the traditional media
and since this is a meeting on
polynomial system solving
i assume that all of you heard about
mixed volume but i want any way to write
down
let's say
the mixed volume is an operator that
takes
n convex bodies
a1
a
and
and
we can make
a minkowski linear combination of them
and i assume those are bodies in
n
so
we know what this volume is
the t t i's are
in the terminates this turns out to be a
polynomial
so if we look at the homogeneous term of
that polynomial that's called the mixed
volume
this was introduced by minkowski in 1901
in connection with with some geometrical
properties of convex bodies
like
area of the border and curvature
so i'm writing this because a lot of
people sometimes in the community of
polynomial system solving
i think i got it wrong
sorry i got it wrong
so a lot of people including myself
mix up things
and uh okay i
take the
nth
derivative i think i need to multiple to
divide
yes i need to divide by factorial n
so that it restricts to the usual volume
when the convex bodies are the same
now
this is also
by the famous bkk bound the number of
solutions
of systems of the form f i of x
equals
sum
for a in some
ai
that this is a finite set
in
zn
so we give
a coefficient a genetic complex number
could you print with a slightly larger
font
okay i'll try try
to switch the font
so if we count the root in c star n
of this sort of systems
system we obtain factorial n times the
wing mix volume so
b k
k
bounds say that the number
of roots
genetic is
n
times v
of a1
a n
and here a i is just
the closure the convex the smallest
convex set containing
the support of this equation
so
what's
m
okay i simplified this talk there is no
m
so anything that looks like an n or an m
is an n
so
we are interested in solving this sort
of equations
so one
approach
that avoids
having to go through
bezel many paths so this
one the bezel number is just the product
of the degrees that's
way too large
so one possibility to do
to do homophobies
while staying with the same structure
was suggested in uh when was that
in 95
by
bern and
burke huber
and it amounts
to introduce a new variable here
and
a
sort of random exponent
called lifting
so when t
equals
1
we have the system we want to solve
and if we make t go to infinity
uh interesting things happen
uh
so
the strategy
for
solving this sort of polynomials
usually is first
to solve the limit form
then to do a homotopy to a system with
random coefficients that's called that
used to be called
hitting
some people don't like this term but
this was coined by diwali it's a good
term and then
to solve the
true system and then there are other
issues that arise like
the end game
so uh
i want to focus in this talk on this
first
issue that is computing
not only the mixed volume
but
also some structure that encodes what
this
initial system is that allows
immediately to recover an initial system
with all the roots
to get global the global solution
this step used to be a bottleneck for
solving
sparse polynomial systems
until a series of breakthroughs
in the uh uh starting in the year 2000
by gowan lee
liam lee
gaolian wu mizutani takeda kojima
and
more recently recently lee and lee in
2011
there may be other recent
improvements that i'm not
aware
now all the
improvements all the algorithms that
exist for computing
this
structure that is the
mix the lower mixed subdivision
are
combinatorial in nature
they
proceed by
exhausting all options
this means
that the only
complexity bounds
that clearly follow from the algorithms
and the only ones that maybe
that i that are known that i am aware
will be exponential in nature
and this is not
the ideal situation
uh what i will
try to explain
here is
what are the ideas behind a new
algorithm
that
provides that
provides also a sort of geometrical
bound on the complexity
and the geometrical bound is in terms of
mixed volumes
it's not what i really wanted to do
i really wanted to do that the
complexity of obtaining this
lower mix subdivision is essentially the
mixed volume
of
the original system there are other
terms that will arise
but overall something that is getting
closer
to get output sensitive uh
i must remind you that even computing
the volume
in terms of traditional complexity is
sharpie complete this is a classical
result by
cassie john
and
the cathedral result just makes it
hopeless to get
something
that is less than sharpie complete for
computing mixed volume taking the
description of the polytopes as input
size
but
in any case if we are going to do
homophobia
we will follow
all the paths
and this forces us to do
as much work as it is the size of this
lower mixed subdivision
also something that i must say is that i
am speaking like if it was just one
algorithm but there are several
different algorithms
when
i speak of on complexity things depend a
lot on the model of complexity
and
if i go
to a practical implementation
i will not do exactly the same algorithm
because of numerical issues this may
increase to the cost of the
implementation
but sometimes i get the results will be
better than the worst case bound
and
now i'll switch
temporarily to the computer
and i must say i strongly agree
with
the email frank
sent us
so the number of slides i will use
is zero
so what i will do here
is to
invoke a virtue of my program
i can do that later
maybe i can do
i may be able to do yes
sorry i
i forgot
control plus may work
so i'm invoking a program
that i've been working for some time
and i will
compute
the mixed volume
of an example that is katsura
17
and i will
leave it running
then i come i'm coming back to my talk
so the computer is doing some work
meanwhile
uh
i will state
the main theorem
uh we don't need the computer uh for the
time being
uh it's here okay
so um
i prefer to use this middle board
for
now because i will need to keep other
things in here
so uh
or maybe maybe you're right
maybe you're all right let's uh
let's
try to do
here is my font large enough yes okay
i will be informal because of the what i
said about the difference between
the
the theoretical algorithm that counts
arithmetic operations
and the number of arithmetic operations
that i actually do
which is slightly
larger per step but of course i do less
steps than
the upper bound
but in any case
if we count
the number
of operations i will obtain
something that
the
algorithm
produces
or
the
cells
in
more or less
in
there was a lot of talk this semester on
finding
hey in haystack i'm not concerned with
this
the algorithms here are randomized
and therefore
we need some sort of average
that i may explain you later
and
it is of the order
and i'm not completely precise on what
i'm writing
but
i will need to add over certain numbers
that i call vd
d equal 1
and
times s
this will be the
input size
the classical input size the number of
monomials times the dimension
so
since i am in formal let's put an anode
of one
i'll take out this thing
maybe i
i can be more imprecise
so there are some logarithms that i'm
not
counting
and this vd
this is the important
term the geometric term
so i had
n convex bodies
let's add another one that is the sum of
them
so vd
will be
related to the mixed volume
and here i put a1
a d minus one
a
and then
a ball
there is a constant here
that we always forget there is a
factorial and that does not harm
anything because it's the same
factorial
oh
wait a second
maybe i have a
an n here
i forgot now if this goes in the
denominator or the numerator
so
if i have this the coefficient may be
made in factorial n ways
okay uh
when i wrote the mixed volume here
inside here there is already a one over
factorial n so i multiply it back to
obtain the expected number of solutions
of an hypothetical polynomial system
albeit
here i have the ball and not
the ai's
and the rather there is an extra factor
that i'm bounding by
half to the n minus d but that may be
better than that
what is this
the
the last factor is maybe the most
interesting that's vn
in the case of vn i have the mixed
volume
of the first d minus one polytopes and
the last and at the end the sum of all
of them
so i should
tell you
more or less how i get here
and show you by some pictures
how the algorithm
proceeds
so um
i'm using some classical tools
one of the most classical tools
in
mathematics is lagrange transform
so we have a function
b
that is the lifting
it is defined
the disjoint union
of the ai the supports not the
not the board the support
and goes into the real numbers
it's legendre transform is a new
function
from a new space that i will call c
space
so
let's call it
lambda uh
i can start with doing the lagrange
transform of just one
of the components so
lambda i let's call b either restriction
to a i lambda i
takes
the number size vector psi
real vector it's in dual space to the
space of uh
of
monomials
and
it takes it to the maximum
over all a
so it's dual space so i should write a
psi minus b
of a this is a convex function i said i
was restricting here to
the eth
component so this is a i and this is bi
and we can also
define
lambda
from r
and to
r
and takes
psi
to
lambda where now lambda is a vector
so this is legend what
i said legendary black rounds this is a
legendary transform i hope i did not
get it wrong
uh
so uh here we have a situation that is
very similar but your writing that low
is not very good because you move the
recording to the block
move the board over move the board over
move the board
but even though it locks
i'll continue on the top so
what we can do with that now
is to take the legendre
transform once again
so
this is a convex function convex domain
everything nice we take a new
legendre transform
and we obtain a function b from a
i
let's go on coordinates again
r
so we take
x it goes to
uh soup of
x
psi minus
lambda
of psi for all psi
psi in the domain
this is a convex function it's the lower
convex rule of
the
of the graph of bi
and we can do that for all the other
variables
now
for every value of psi
i draw it in one dimension for the
moment
so for every value of psi
there is an extra sorry
sorry in my picture
side leaves here
so for every value of psi
i have to look at the vector psi minus
one
and it attains a maximum at some points
in the um
in the graph
of the function
so i count the number of points i
subtract one
and i call this number m i
of x i equal
number of times
max
is
pertained
minus one
this is also the dimension
of the lower convex rule
i think i'm
going to slowly so let's say
that
if i fix let's go to the computer again
okay so i need the projection please
it's coming yes
okay so let's
let's see
something is
going wrong
no
you need to just
press on them yeah okay
okay so uh now i need to
come back and change
so sorry i
well i lost my
okay
just a second then
so i'm
okay
let's look at the polynomial system so
i'll file
open
and i'll choose a system like
uh
this is this is this is 9.3
this is a test system
so it's here
let's solve it
and let's look at the mix subdivision
so so
i have to explain
uh what you are actually seeing i'm just
turning here something uh
this the dimension is four
but i'm projecting on three space you
are seeing
c space
so uh when the contacts
dimensions the mi that i defined are
equal to one
this means
that
the
there are here exactly two monomials
that survive
this is what we want to find those are
the cold so-called mix cells
the points that are glowing in front of
you are mixed cells
if i allow the last
m n
to drop by one eventually
but i maintain
that m one m two t and
d minus one are larger or equal than
one then
i can still get
places where one of the first mi is
equal to three and then i get other
cells that are not growing
and i can pass from once to the other
by some pivoting this implies
that i have a sum of the mis that is n
minus one
this is something that is called the
tropical curve
and
the algorithm worked by exploring
tropical curves
so here we have we are at the top level
we are seeing a certain tropical curve
that needs to be explored
and
the trouble is
that this is not necessarily connected
so i need to write the part so i have
more pictures to show
maybe after the talk
uh but then
at this point
what i need to do
is to show also that besides
the
the complexity bound
i have actual results this
worked in some point
i need to press enter
okay
so it worked in 613 seconds
for an example that
appeared
to take something like 21 hours in the
previous paper by lee and lee
thank you and i and i apologize for
being out of time i will not show you
the most striking images
someone could ask for them
so you can ask me about connectedness i
have an image
you can ask me
why it is
randomized and
about random flags i have another
picture yeah yeah
why do you use random walks and they
take a lot of time too uh
okay let's let's go back to the um
let's go back to the previous example uh
random walks take really a lot of time
but there is another alternative
uh
that brings some complexity problems uh
let's see uh i'll how do i
change here
so this is screen two
so um
here i need to explore this graph which
happens
to be sometimes connected
sometimes not connected and in most very
big examples it is not
so uh what i can do
is to uh
intersect
with an hyperplane and a fine hyperplane
so if i intersect with a funny
hyperplane which is not visible here but
i will make it visible first by
increasing
the
visual radius
increasing
a little bit the size of this thing
and doing some strange operation i don't
have in this picture i'm sorry let's uh
i'll i'll make another picture
uh
open
let's get to the slower smaller
dimensional picture
dimension three
and uh
now i will
do something that i call the full
algorithm
so in the full algorithm i
you see there is something
at the end
sorry
sorry so this is
uh i'm sorry so okay
this is a better vision so
here
there is a plane that is getting close
okay so i will
perform the same algorith recursively on
that
other plane at infinity
uh
we decrease the dimension by one and so
on
theorem each of the spikes
of this
tropical
uh
sorry
here we have a
tropical variety
what is a system of three equations and
three variables yes
and what's the curve what's the tropical
curve so the tropical curve is in three
spaces
okay this is in three space so i want to
have
two points of contact with the first
polytope at least and two points of
contact with the second polytope
so that's the curve that you get by
intersecting the first two tropical
surfaces
yes
and
then i want
to do some recursion but i need
genericity so i take a random uh a fine
plane and cut by your random affine
plane
um
theorem every connected component of
this curve
will cut this uh
random plane at least once
so uh i go reducing
to
problems of smaller dimension
so
the question is that
well
this number here
is the number
uh of mixed cells
uh sorry not of mixed cells let's see
it's the number of points of the
tropical curve
if i go uh
to the
other dimensions
i originally expected this number to
decrease but that's not the case in some
very large examples it increases
and then it decreases again
so in order to avoid that i use a random
search
it works fine but it has a big
disadvantage that is that i don't know
that i am over
so i i pay you huge complexity cost that
is what johannes has
has seen in the
in the other listing
just by
overshooting
and still there is no absolute certitude
if i want certitude
i have the theorem
that is good uh
theoretically
but that's not enough to get better
timing than
in the other papers
and then i need i have
some
other
issues to worry here you see those
points are very close this is a common
feature
there is a conditioning problem that
seems to be structural in some cases
so i need to be careful about numerical
stability and at some point this forces
me to send that flag to infinity
and use non-standard numbers but this is
another story
also there is another reason to
send that flag to infinity that is
another picture that i have
it's actually pre-computed
so
i'll show you what
you will see in a few minutes
i'll call the picture first and then you
may ask me why because it will take some
time to load
as this is loading let's thank gregario
again
ah there you go okay so uh what is this
this is uh this comes from a model from
acoustics and this is quite typical of
what happens in say the the
in the in the center of the amoeba